[Music]
Disney Princesses play a part in such
outstanding stories that we often forget
they're all just teenagers some as young
as 14 years old talented artists
reimagined Disney Princesses as what
they would really look like as rebel
teenagers else's tattoos look amazing
never miss another Disney video again by
subscribing to our Channel
give this video a thumbs up if you're a
Disney fan today we're discussing 10
Disney Princesses reimagined as
teenagers Ariel Ariel was 16 in the
Little Mermaid but how many 16-year olds
do you know that are the daughters of
the king of Atlantis there are actually
seven but how many of them hate living
underwater and desperately want to have
feet yeah probably not that many the
original Ariel is absolutely gorgeous
and her looks were based on the very
talented actress Alyssa Milano but
needless to say those looks are only
reserved for some people teenagers these
days come in all shapes and sizes
just like they should be but they also
come with a couple of piercings and
tattoos
check out this version of the Little
Mermaid Ariel's rocking an eyebrow
piercing a septum piercing and a couple
of tattoos on her shoulders her hair is
dark and she's clearly in her teenage
punk phase what do you think would this
be an accurate representation of the
Little Mermaid as a teenager she was
quite a rebellious character so who
knows perhaps the underwater world has a
tattoo parlor we can totally see Ariel's
dad with some tattoos but if you're not
a fan of the punk style Ariel perhaps
this teenage Ariel might be a better
option how cute is this Little Mermaid
reimagined by deviantART artist Agustina
this is Ariel the school girl with
glasses styled hair and a chic outfit we
wonder what her favorite subject in
school would be rapunzel rapunzel was 18
and tangled so we never got to see what
she'd actually be like if she was a
teenager but luckily the internet is
full of fan art and edits to show us how
Disney Princesses would look like in
different situations
just imagine what they would be like if
they were real-life teenagers this is
what Rapunzel would look like if she
ever went through the real teenage
rebellion her beautiful blonde hair is
now gone but we're totally digging this
new look dark purple hair dark lipstick
dark makeup this Rapunzel is clearly
going through her goth phase and check
this out
it looks like Pascal the chameleon also
picked up some of the darkness around
him early designs for Pascal were
actually purple in blue but the
animators chose green because it looked
best with Rapunzel's blonde hair so
maybe this purple thing they got going
on isn't so far off from reality
if Rapunzel had purple hair what color
do you think Pascal would be not a fan
of the goth Rapunzel here she is with a
little lighter choice for a hair color a
couple of tattoos and a system of a down
t-shirt check out Pascal's Mohawk pretty
cool right
Milan Milan is possibly one of the most
inspiring Disney Princesses ever she's
determined selfless and doesn't care
when she's put down by a bunch of guys
she's strong and ready to train until
she becomes the best come on who doesn't
love Mulan and she's also somewhat based
on a Chinese legend of a woman called
Mulan who seemed equally as impressive
Milan is just 16 yes
rapunzel is older than her even though
this would be very hard to believe based
on their personalities but she's not
really a typical teenager right here's
what Mulan would really look like if she
was a teenager in the modern world
she would have glasses earrings for
stretched ears piercings and neck
tattoos what do you think a little over
the top or an exact representation we
definitely think Mulan would have
rebelled at some point in her life
especially if she ever went to a typical
high school although we have no doubt
that she'd be super popular her newfound
strength would probably get her in some
trouble speaking of tattoos Mulan is
actually a pretty popular design choice
when it comes to getting inked check out
these totally fierce Mulan tattoos if
you could get a Disney tattoo which
princess would you choose Belle the
seventeen-year-old Belle actually isn't
that far away from a modern-day teenager
sure
no teenager wears her style of dresses
but there are plenty of bookworms out
there did you know that one of Belle's
favorite books is actually Aladdin well
at least according to a fan theory Belle
describes the book as something with
far-off places daring sword fights magic
spells and a prince in disguise and many
things she's talking about Aladdin with
this teenage version of Belle still be
is obsessed with books check her out her
hair is purple and she has a septum and
an eyebrow piercing and what's that a
tattoo on her neck we wouldn't be
surprised if that tattoo is actually a
quote from one of her favorite books
imagine this would be the real Belle
would the story change or would her
looks affect anything bet she didn't
know that the original Belle's
personality was actually inspired by
Katharine Hepburn's portrayal of Joe
March from the movie Little Women her
look was based on Julie Andrews and the
sound of music and even Judy Garland in
The Wizard of Oz no wonder why Bell is
so gorgeous we think that seeing Belle
with a couple of piercings and tattoos
would definitely spice things up Jasmine
did you know that Princess Jasmine is
just 15 years old judging by her
personality she definitely looks older
although technically a teenager the
Internet reimagined her into what she
actually looked like as a modern-day
fifteen-year-old what do you think of
this she's really showing some attitude
isn't she well this fifteen-year-old
isn't having any of it based on this
picture to match her long dark hair
she's wearing a dark lipstick and a
cardigan on top of her regular outfit
but other than that she's probably the
one princess that hasn't really changed
that much just wait until you see what
the internet did to Elsa but you'll have
to wait to see what else it looks like
did you know that jasmine was actually
inspired by the sister of one of the
animators working on Aladdin they used
her facial features to create jasmine
but there was another anonymous young
lady that inspired Jasmine's long dark
hair they never found out her name
we're glad this reimagined teenage
Jasmine didn't change her iconic hair as
we absolutely love it we definitely see
a bit more attitude coming out in this
jasmine and we bet she'd be even more
adamant to marry for love and not for
anything else
you go girl Pocahontas Pocahontas is one
of the few older official Disney
Princesses and her personality
definitely shows a more mature side so
no wonder this talented artist
reimagined her as a serious student
this illustration belongs to a
deviantART user called hye-young 86 and
we absolutely love it unlike other
princesses on our list
Pocahontas definitely looks like she's
the most grown-up and ready to take on
the world so what do you think of this
modern-day teenage Pocahontas she looks
like a stylish and definitely popular
college freshman we love how the artist
put her iconic blue necklace on her
dress and kept the native theme in her
clothing by adding a dark fringe jacket
don't you think Pocahontas looks like a
model we bet she's currently auditioning
for America's best top model and we bet
she'd made it to it
the last top five if Pocahontas did go
to college what do you think her
favorite subject would be would she be
the sporty cheerleader type or do you
think she would be a straight-a on a
student who meets her true love John
Smith on an exchange in the UK now that
would be a modern-day Pocahontas movie
Merida this reimagined teenage version
of Merida was created by the talented
deviantART artist Shannon Eko
doesn't this Merida give off an anime
vibe it's such a cute take on the
usually very fierce and fearless Disney
Princess Merida is the sixteen-year-old
daughter of King Fergus and Queen
Eleanor who ruled their Scottish Kingdom
unlike some of the other ladies on this
list Merida doesn't want to be royal
instead she wants to take control of her
own life and showcase her amazing
archery skills
she's rebellious headstrong and she's
definitely not your typical princess but
the reimagined teenage Merida definitely
looks different don't you think sure her
wild curly hair is still there with an
added pink hair bow at the top we love
her cute pink top with the bear and
denim shorts and is that an iPod she's
listening to that is very modern of her
well it turns out that even though this
Merida is nowhere similar to the real
brave princess Merida's look makes a lot
of people angry when Disney made Merida
as their official princess many
complained that the new archery princess
doesn't show the true value of brave
anymore it even got the creator Brenda
Chapman talking she said that the new
version of the Disney Princess no longer
focuses on the main message you don't
need to be just a pretty face that waits
around for Romans Tiana
speaking of progressive and favorite
Disney Princesses what do you think of
Tiana in our eyes she's one of the most
underrated princesses who knows how to
work hard and do anything she sets her
mind to perhaps this wisdom comes with
age
do you know Tiana is 19 years old we've
completely missed what she would look
like as a normal teenager but luckily
the Internet is there to give us a
pretty good idea
this teenage Tiana was illustrated by
bev johnson and the artists managed to
show us a different side of tiana what
do you think of this we are in love with
her green layered dress and her frog
purse
unlike other princesses this artist
decided to also change her shape and
give her far more realistic body size
she commented that a lot of people
reimagined
me princesses and high fashion and few
tend to do casual versions her
illustrations have gone viral and we can
definitely see why we love this version
of Tiana she's happy she has muscles but
she can still rock a light green dress
do you think a teenage tiana would still
dream about opening her own restaurant
or which she have different goals and
ambitions Cinderella this illustration
might just be our favorite it comes from
bev johnson who also designed tiana
there's just something so simple about
it and it certainly suits Cinderella
although she looks shy the teenage
Cinderella is very cute
we love the pastel colors of her outfit
there are definitely what the real
Cinderella would wear her hair is
gorgeously styled what do you think
Cinderella would study at school and
favorite subjects something tells us
she'd be very into fashion perhaps maybe
even shoe making the artist kept
Cinderella modest and dressed her in a
neutral colored blouse with a cute
collarbone and a light blue skirt this
teenage Cinderella is certainly a
fashionista well if you're looking for
the same kind of clothes Cinderella is
wearing it might be worth checking with
Lauren Conrad the famous designer
created a line of Cinderella inspired
clothes and they're really close to the
real deal we think Cinderella would
definitely approve of this collection
did you know that Cinderella saved Walt
Disney's company they were in huge
amounts of debt and took a risk making
Cinderella without knowing whether it
would be successful or not
we're so grateful for Cinderella's
inspiring success and this version of
the teenage princess with the lost shoe
definitely shows us she would always be
humble Elsa and last but not least as
our favorite Disney Queen who managed to
take the world by storm
in 2013 everyone became obsessed with
frozen and the story of Anna Elsa
Kristoff and Olaf we bet you're humming
do you want to build a snowman to
yourself right now
Elsa is 21 years old and although she's
an unofficial Disney Princess she's the
oldest queen of the bunch there's just
something about her that makes her
different from the rest could it be her
cool hair or her awesome powers although
we didn't get to see what Elsa would
look like at 15 the internet decided to
reimagine her and give her a bit of a
rebellious flair check out this goth
version of Elsa we are absolutely in
love with the pink hair and she looks
like she's covered in tattoos flowers
diamonds
what else do you think she has it also
seems like the teenage Elsa really has
her makeup skills down and we let the
little heart under her I'm you really
wouldn't want to mess with this version
of Elsa want to see what both of the
frozen sisters would look like together
they'd definitely experiment with their
hair and we're loving this look if you
could get a Disney tattoo what would you
get let us know in the comments below
and don't forget to give this video a
big thumbs up for more Disney videos
check out 15 Disney Princesses
reimagined by amazing artists see you
next time
[Music]